dans la tente finalement d'élection du
gouvernement puisque on attend un
éventuel déconfinement 11 mais qui n'est
pas réellement
sur toutefois on espère quand même une
ouverture dans l'été éventuellement en
proposant une carte réduite et puis fait
un petit peu tekoe puisque puisqu'on est
loin de connaissances à savoir si on
ouvrira réellement dans l'été et sous
quelles conditions on va réouvrir en
format épicerie et restauration emporté
plats cuisinés et produits crus aussi
puisque en étant restaurateurs bien sûr
on a les approvisionnements on peut les
avoir on allait des légumes comme avant
de la région on a toutes les volailles
de la région mais ça aussi on a tout ce
qu'il faut
donc on peut cuisiner qu'on va cuisiner
des plats cuisinés et on va vendre aussi
des produits bruts légumes les fraises
les asperges de blaye adapter notre
restauration maintenant donc on
s'organise on cherchait fournisseurs de
nouveaux fournisseurs
on adapte notre restaurant et on
on se fait connaître d'une autre façon
on essaie de penser à des plats qu'ils
puissent s envoyer à la fois qui change
qui puisse permettre aux gens du
quartier de manger des plats variés
s'en est trop cher les qui soit aussi
bon à l'envoi qu'une fois à la maison